olympians train for almost their entire
lives with the goal
of winding up here that goal
comes at a heavy price it costs a lot
it really honestly does between
the training and the traveling coaches
fees
quite a bit it might pay off and they
can wind up here because a complete
breakfast with wheaties
is good tasting and good for you
but to get there requires years of
financial investment you're going to be
in a club program that's going to cost
about 5 000 a year there's also fees to
be paid for
going to competitions if you go away to
an away meet you're going to travel
you may fly you may drive you're going
to have to stay at a hotel
um all those expenses add up even
relatively accessible sports like
swimming
can cost athletes thousands every year
those expenses start as a child
and only get more expensive over time
costing olympians and their families
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
hopes of making it to the olympic games
here's a look at how much it costs to
become an olympic swimmer
unlike other sports there aren't a bunch
of things you need to buy
the cost of equipment is subjected to
preference but competitive swimmers use
special swimsuits called tech suits
which can add up men's tech suits like
this one can cost up to four hundred
dollars
and women's can cost up to six hundred
dollars
they could last one meet you know
three or four swims it all depends about
how long
you want to wear them if they rip or
tear or wear out
you know the suit has it fits very
tightly if you buy two three or four
suits a year
you know you're spending two thousand
bucks on bathing suits some caps and
goggles are not as expensive
and can cost up to 300 per year and
there's one more piece of important
equipment
a pool so many schools like swim labs a
usa swimming officially recognized
professional swim lesson provider
has locations all across the us their
location in westchester new york
offers private lessons that cost 349
dollars per month
regardless of where young swimmers learn
how to swim competitive swimmers will
need
access to olympic size pools for real
training in the sport
this usually means joining a club's
competitive swimming team
welcome to meadowbrook it's the swim
facility where phelps and fellow olympic
medalist katie hoff
both got their start usc swimming's
number one ranked swim club in the
united states
is ncap or the nation's capital swim
club in 2021 a club membership in the
gold one category for elite swimmers at
their washington dc location
will set a swimmer back about five
thousand eight hundred and sixty dollars
per year swimmers start swimming for
their local clubs that are around 8
years old but usually will start no
later than 12. i mean there's a lot of
club programs in the country in
metropolitan area there's well over 100
different programs
and across the country you're talking
about thousands of clubs
without club swimming we wouldn't have
an olympic team they continue to compete
for clubs until they reach the
collegiate level
where many of them begin swimming for
division one universities
and some continue both so by the time
kids reach the college level
they've already spent 16 to 40 thousand
dollars on
club views alone in 2019 usa swimming
had 412
000 members and over 3 000 clubs who
paid more than 22 million dollars in
fees
they're the governing body of the sport
responsible for organizing events and
recording official times for national
rankings
registered members pay an annual fee of
60
that fee allows swimmers to compete in
sanctioned competitions
in one of those sanctioned competitions
are the olympic trials
according to coach collins some elite
swimmers might seek private coaching to
be more competitive
and depending on the coach private
coaching can run a student more than one
thousand dollars per month total
expenses can vary widely
from person to person usa swimming
estimates expenses for olympic hopefuls
can be anywhere from 25 to 40 thousand
dollars for proper coaching
equipment training and travel each year
and depending on the swimmers training
program they may also need a budget for
other costs like a nutritionist
physical therapist or a gym membership
the cost of competing in any non-ncaa
competitions that collegiate swimmers
enter will come out of their own pocket
swimmers who choose the collegiate route
get access to all the necessary
amenities and facilities they need
as well as physical therapists trainers
coaches
and doctors olympians like michael
andrew chose to skip the collegiate
route to focus all their efforts on
olympic training
however that means the cost of their
coaching training
travel entrance fees and lodging is
all on them it is much harder to
be an individual athlete um training by
yourself
in reaching those top levels since 1978
the united states olympic and paralympic
committee has not been funded by the u.s
government
so u.s olympians rely on grants and
sponsorships to offset the out-of-pocket
costs for their training
usa swimming gives yearly stipends to
top swimmers on the national team
they also provide bonuses for swimmers
who make it onto the olympic team
usa swimming spends an average of 10
million dollars per year in support of
national team athletes
and according to them most olympic and
paralympic hopefuls make less than 20
thousand dollars a year
coach khan says there are sponsored
clubs who can afford to pay their
summers to be a part of their team
because you need to have money to live
you need money to
train and you don't have that money
who's going to help you do it the cost
of being an elite olympic swimmer is a
full-time investment of training both
in and out of the pool as in most
professional sports
the best athletes earn the biggest
paychecks and in swimming
those paychecks come almost exclusively
in the form of large individual
endorsement deals
and sponsorships
[Applause]